so what happens if this uh this uh
election is super close
in the end well let's bring in rachel
rizzo who's uh director of programs
at the truman national security project
they've prepared simulations
of exactly at that scenario welcome to
dw um let's start with this flurry of
republican
lawsuits to try and stop vote counting
were you expecting this
we were expecting this we knew that if
the election
process started going and it was clear
that biden was inching ahead
there was going to be an issue from the
white house and the incumbent president
trump
would do everything that he can to hang
on
to his presidency so we are seeing
lawsuits we are seeing him try to
um stop votes even in some states which
is extremely concerning but these are
all things that
we um like you said played through in a
simulation at the truman center um and
that we definitely
expected and knew was coming all right
so at the moment joe biden's just six or
seven
votes away from the 270
electoral college votes he needs when do
you expect a winner to be announced
we're not sure yet so we're all waiting
with baited breath to see what happens
in nevada and there should be
a significant update on the vote tallies
there at around noon eastern time
if um joe biden does get the six
electoral votes from nevada as well as
the 11 electoral votes that he's waiting
on
um from arizona that brings him to 270
and the race
is effectively over there's no path for
victory for president trump
however we are still waiting to see what
happens with pennsylvania and georgia
those results could take days and
there's
legal challenges unlikely to um
drag this out much
yes so in any state if if the leader is
ahead by less than one percent
the other uh person can can force a
recount
however historically those recounts
haven't netted
very many additional votes for whoever
is behind so
even if the president does try to force
a recount it's unlikely that that would
change the outcome if biden
is ahead even by a slim margin
rather shockingly for some people we
have seen um
pictures of uh shops being barricaded
and police
and and civil uh departments making
ready for
civil unrest and is that a significant
risk
well i think over the last couple of
days we
have seen that risk decrease i'm over
here in washington dc and it's been
really shocking to see
barricades go up downtown all of the
businesses
in downtown washington are boarded up
but i think
it goes to show that you know american
democracy
is still strong and what has ended up
happening over the past few days
even given that the the votes are are
not
finished yet given that the the outcome
is unclear
we haven't seen unrest we haven't seen
riots and i think that's a good thing so
i think
as as the days inch on those right those
potential for riots and unrest becomes
less and less at least here in
washington
good talking to you thank you for
joining us rachel rizzo from the truman
national security project
thank you only uh
many of president trump's tweets since
election day have been flagged by
twitter for containing disputed or
misleading content
so let's take a look at his latest post
it contains a headline from far
right media outlet breitbart alleging
vote counting chaos in the closely
contested state of michigan
the breitbart article says the trump
campaign has been denied proper access
to the accounting process
in the city of detroit
so let's take a closer look at these
claims with their dw
fact checker yosha weber welcome joshua
what have you found out
our team debunked this story and
breitbart reported on poll workers in
detroit covering windows
as onlookers outside tried to watch as
ballots were being counted
and obviously trying to get into the
polling station
the police then did push back crowds who
had begun
pounding on the doors and windows and
yelling stop the count
which might have been influenced by the
president trump who earlier said that
all voting should be stopped however
what the breitbart article didn't
mention was the fact that the election
official
said the people could not enter the room
due to a capacity concerns
the allowed number of people in this
room was exceeded and there were
democratic
and republican poll watchers beside
media and lawyers
all that already in that room so
according to present lawyers
the tensions in there began when
republican poll watchers had
intimidated poll workers by taking off
their masks
getting too close to the workers or
begin even
verbally aggressive to to be to them
they
tried to tell workers to stop counting
so this was a serious problem for the
workers
the claims of the republicans being
excluded were without reason in my
opinion
okay so uh other members of the trump
campaign are
casting doubt on the results of this
election um let's listen to uh mr
trump's
lawyer rudy giuliani talking about
postal votes
in the state of pennsylvania not a
single republican has been able to look
at any one of these mail ballots they
could be from mars as far as we're
concerned or they could be from the
democratic national committee
joe biden could have voted 50 times as
far as we know or 5 000 times
the ballots could be from camden
philadelphia unfortunately and would say
this about my own city has a reputation
for voter fraud
well joshua weber any substance to that
cascade of claims
well the former mayor of new york and
associate attorney general should know
better
male voters cannot vote 50 or 5
000 times like he said not joe biden or
anybody else
to vote by mail you have to be a
registered voter
and you have one vote according to
several studies
fraud is rare in u.s elections a data
collection by
the loyola school of law only listed 45
incidents of voter fraud in the last 20
years so that is not much and
that in relation to more than 1 billion
battles cast
the head of the study confirmed to dw
fact checkers
but rudy giuliani insisted that mail in
ballots in pennsylvania could be from
everywhere from mars from even dead
people voting
he doesn't deliver any evidence for this
we have to say and
an independent election observers didn't
find
cases like this so far giuliani called
the local judge
later a political hack because his party
wasn't able to get closer than 20 feet
to the ballots
he claimed and it wasn't possible to
observe the election by the republicans
we couldn't verify that but we have no
reports of a big fraud in philadelphia
like giuliani says
and he is the one who has been sent by
donald trump to challenge the election
results in pennsylvania so if you ask me
his statement has to be seen in this
context as the trump side prepares a
legal fight
in several battleground states now right
i'm glad i did ask you in that case
let's have a look at the democratic
candidate joe biden he made an address
in wilmington
and was optimistic about his chances
only three presidential campaigns in the
past
have defeated an incumbent president
when it's finished
god willing will be the fourth
well what do you think joshua is that
true
no it's not in the history of the united
states 10
incumbent presidents have been defeated
at the polls when seeking a second term
of their presidency
10 presidents lost in presidential
elections
and two more in national conventions of
their parties so the first one was john
adams
who was defeated by thomas jefferson
back in 1800 already
and the last one was george bush senior
who lost against a certain bill clinton
in 1992
so if biden wins he will be at number 11
and not four of this ranking all right
dw fact checker uh joshua weber thank
you so much